THAT JUSTICE IS IN FACT BLIND IN
THIS COUNTRY PEERED WHERE USING
FAITH IN.
>> DEVIN NUNES REPRESENTS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HE IS ON THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
WHY WOULDN'T THE DOJ PROSECUTE
JIM COMEY FOR A CRIME THAT HE
HAS ADMITTED TO COMMITTING?
>> I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING IN
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT.
I THINK EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD
WATCH WHAT YOU DECIDE.
I WANT TO ACTUALLY MAKE SURE
THOUGH THAT YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
JOHN SOLOMON PUT REPORTED ON
HERE.
I THINK IT MAY BE GOT TAKEN A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF CONTEXT.
THE IG'S WHO REPORTEDLY
ACCORDING TO SOLOMON SOURCES
MADE A RIGHT RECOMMENDATION,
OKAY?
JUST BECAUSE THE DOJ IS NOT
GOING TO ACT UNDER THAT
RECOMMENDATION DOES NOT MEAN
THAT HE'S NOT GOING TO BE
FURTHER LOOKED AT SO REMEMBER,
THE U.S. ATTORNEY IN CONNECTICUT
NOW IS TAKING ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION IN.
SO HE'S TAKING IN OUR CRIMINAL
REFERRALS, FOR EXAMPLE.
SO LOOK, I HAVEN'T DISCLOSED WHO
YOU HAVE REFERRED CRIMINALLY BUT
ONE COULD GUESS IT'S HIGHLY
LIKELY THAT WE WOULD USE PEOPLE
THAT I HAVE LEAKED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
SO THEY ARE NOT GOING TO ACT ON
ANY OF OUR REFERRALS FOR THOSE
HAVE ALL BEEN GIVEN TO THE U.S.
ATTORNEY IN CONNECTICUT.
MY GUESS IS THE SAME HOLDS TRUE
FOR THE IG.
EVERYTHING SHOULD BE GIVEN TO
THE ATTORNEY IN CONNECTICUT.
SO IF I WAS JAMES COMEY, I
WOULDN'T BE WALKING IN THE
CORNFIELDS OF IOWA RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: SO IT IS COMMON,
AND IT SOUNDS A COMBINE OR
DETAIL BUT I DON'T GET IS, IF
COMEY IS IN FACT INDICTED FOR
THAT CRIME THAT HE COMMITTED AND
ADMITTED TO COMMITTING, IF THAT
HAPPENS, WILL HIS HOUSE BE RATED
BY, SAY, 30 ARMED FEDERAL
AGENTS?
AND THE CONCLUSION OF CNN?
>> WELL, I WOULD GUESS PROBABLY
NOT BECAUSE I BELIEVE U.S.
ATTORNEY JOHN DURHAM IS ACTUALLY
A MAN WHO DOES THE BLIND LEADING
THAT DOESN'T PARDON PARTISAN AT
ALL
AND UNLIKE WHAT YOU SAW WITH OF
THE MUELLER DOSSIER TEAM WHICH
WE NOW KNOW HE WASN'T EVEN
CHARGED WITH THAT INVESTIGATION
PAIRED SO I DON'T BELIEVE YOU
WILL SEE THAT BUT I DO BELIEVE
THAT JAMES COMEY WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND THERE IS ONE
OTHER POINT THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
MAKE, THE IG ALSO HAS IMPORTANT
POWERS.
THE IG DOES NOT HAVE THE POWER,
THOUGH, TO INVESTIGATE OR COMPEL
PEOPLE TO BE INTERVIEWED THAT
DON'T WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE OR IN THE GOVERNMENT.
SO, I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN HESITANT
TO, ALTHOUGH I APPRECIATE WITH
THE IG IS DOING, THEY ARE
LIMITED WHERE JOHN DURHAM IS NOT
LIMITED.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY LOOKING AT
THIS.
SO THERE ARE A LOT MORE PEOPLE
TO NEED TO BE INTERVIEWED, EVEN
IN OUR INVESTIGATION PEERED WE
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT ARM THAT WE
COULD GO OUT AND CONDUCT MORE
INTERVIEWS.
BUT, THE FBI AND THE U.S.
ATTORNEY IN CONNECTICUT, THEY
HAVE, THEY ARE BUILDING THEIR
TEAM.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE INTERVIEWED
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IS
THAT IT'S NOT JUST JAMES COMEY
THAT GETS LOOKED AT BUT THIS
WHOLE FIASCO THAT IS A PART.
YOU JUST TOUCH ON IT A LITTLE
BIT IN HER OPENING.
THE WORST THAT'S BEEN DONE, THE
LEAKING IS REALLY BAD AND IT WAS
WRONG BUT IT WAS DONE TO INCITE
A SPECIAL COUNSEL AN EMPLOYEE A
MILLION AMERICANS.
BUT THE WORST I WOULD ARGUE OF
ALL OF THIS, THE SPYING ON A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN BEGAN IN THE
FIRST PLACE, LONG BEFORE THEY
TOLD CONGRESS IT BEGAN SO THIS
BEGAN IN EARLY 2016 AND IT WAS
DONE IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
IT DOESN'T GET WORSE THAN THAT.
>> Tucker: YES.
BY THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.